but we have a very special guest they
allowed him into the club really I mean
we're gonna have to raise our standards
and our guest is with I think into the
studio well thank you yeah so yes I'm
here with the man behind it all here at
the st. Louis chess club Rex Sinquefield
Rex an avid fan you've been following
the tournament I have them yeah what do
you think so far and I think that the
theme of this tournament could be I
think someone said it the other day
missed opportunities it seems almost
every day somebody gets the lead Magnus
and he blows it Fabiano and he blows it
you know today going the other way it
looks like ding Liron winning and by the
way I want to first welcome jovan Co to
the colonies I hope you give the Queen a
good report on how we're doing over here
[Music]
nice and I want to compliment all you
once again the greatest broadcast team
of any sport in the world and Maurice
that includes you that's right well Rex
the tour is expanding and it seems that
every year we're adding more stops for
anymore different ideas we have a
different time control here in Croatia
are you a fan here of the delay and of
the note added bonus on move 40 I think
that Maurice has converted me I like
this is a 100 game in 130 yes I guess if
they allowed me total degrees of freedom
I'd say game in 140 no increment no
delay I'll throw in an extra 10 minutes
because we take the delay away right
it's been a controversial decision some
people loving it some people are hating
it I don't like delays at all they're
very counterintuitive for me but I'm a
simple fellow so what do you expect you
know well it's not an easy opinion I
know that Garry Kasparov is a big
exponent of the delay system he likes
the fact that no time is added and some
people are very angry yes they don't
know increment either some people are
worried that you get to this rook versus
rook positions and you're just gonna try
to flag your opponent that's the problem
you know that was Bobby Fischer's
argument and that still is a good art
I have to concede that so I might be
contradicting myself right a lot of
choices here but we've been
experimenting we're gonna have this
thing Lois rapid and blitz here again
and we have so much talent in America
currently for the top ten players in the
world top sorry four of the top 15
players in the world are currently
American what can you say about that I
think it's it's incredible I think we
could just bring Fischer back and we
have five unfortunately that might be a
little difficult to do even the genie of
the lamp has rules against that well
have you been following today's round
you said that ding Lauren you were
impressed by his victory I just drove in
from the country and so I was on the
highway and people have told me don't
watch chess while you're driving at
least that's what the Highway Patrol
officer well Rex what do you think is
missing from the tour what would you add
if you could do it oh wow that's a very
good question we sign here this tour
stops so far a lot of chess to be played
this year of course the next year I'm
very busy chess calendar with the
candidates and the world champion versus
things up a little bit because of the
big feet important feeding events
I think the tour is really good I
couldn't come up and say right now what
else we need I mean a lot of the big
improvement was due to the inspiration
of Garry Kasparov you know and thinks
there's something missing I'd love to
hear it oh it's obvious Rex come on come
on well it's obviously missing about the
tour as it should be for the World
Championship well that's a very good
point I have sometimes said to people
maybe we could have the grand chess -
our world champion simply name the
winner that each year we're not going to
start a new Federation we're not going
to go back in that direction but just
see if people start to accept it as
something like that mm-hmm I don't want
to start a war here you know good why
not well definitely a mixed kind of
tournaments including rapid and blitz
and some of this event some wild cards
that are adding
a lot to the tournaments we've seen it
in the past session Wei Yi I think was
very impressive on the first half do you
think that for this kind of tour we
should stick to rapid blitz and
classical or do you even think that more
kinds of chess should be added we could
consider adding Fischer random one thing
I would say and I know I'll get shot
down on this one is that I don't like
the idea of mix modalities where we use
a rapid or a blitz to settle a classical
event I think that's just horrible it's
like running a marathon and two guys are
tired they go okay you're gonna run a
50-yard dash to see who wins that's just
insane so totally incongruous that's my
humble opinion seems to be shared by
many players especially after the World
Championship last year we're well
Fabiano clearly match match against
Magnus Carlsen in the classical but in
the rapid it was just a different story
right and I think there's an entirely
different event right and so we're
mixing two events and I just think it
doesn't make any sense at all that
there's a recent innovation innovation
it's a recent development I don't think
it's much of an innovation that was
never done historically in chess right
and you've been converted a little bit
into those rapid and blitz events I know
that you're I like them I really would
love a a rapid game that's longer than
20 minutes say 45 minutes sir I believe
about 20 years ago or so yeah sir yeah
Karpov and Kasparov played an event in
New York exactly and it was something
like game in 45 or game in 60 they had
two games a day two two weekend days in
a row that's right that's right and it
was very very popular but actually in
New York City itself the Big Apple
I think Maurice was during the
commentary it got a lot and I mean a lot
of publicity I paid money to watch it
online I'm a chess fan too I would love
to see Kasparov and Karpov play about
the master
well we've also been adding Fischer
random here into the mix we're gonna say
Lewis Chess Club do you think we'll be
seeing a lot more of that I think we
might because Gary is really a big fan
of that and online my chess teacher
Jennifer I'm playing heard Fischer
random right now and how's that going it
I so far I think it's okay she was
crushing me but I think I cut the head
off the snake so you're saying that
you're improving and your chest is
progressing rapidly I don't know about
rapidly I think I'm improving I know I'm
I know a lot more than I knew two years
ago she gives me this incredibly
difficult homework and right now we're
going over the Grunfeld and there's a
lot there I just didn't I spent five
hours this weekend working on a homework
project for her where you pay two boards
and what your question that jovi had for
you remember the Basques system the idea
is that we're gonna play two games at
once so we're playing assignment against
each other I'm gonna play white and one
game and black and the other and you've
got to decide the cool time control have
you seen that rats the bank a wallet but
I don't really remember watching it very
carefully about a did a fast version of
it when that becomes just crazy but if
you did it in classical chess where you
have two you're playing two games of
chess could be quite interesting can I
enjoy what we saw I know I thought that
was really a lot of fun
I also Rex as we're just telling the
Cairns Cup I thought that was fantastic
last year you had this year talk about
the carrots cut well a lot of decisive
games yeah that was the big deal I think
is genie happy I think she was very
happy and I think women deserve their
own high level tournaments I have to add
I was absolutely over the moon to see a
tournament like this we could we got a
production crew like this and there was
amazing coverage their gains are
fantastic and I for me it was a great
honor to follow
I enjoyed commentary very much sorry to
butt in here Alejandro but Rex I
garry kasparov has been on with maurice
and he says garry kasparov said that the
feed a calendar were there for
tournaments it's so full that maybe next
year the grand chest tour has to
unfortunately just because of the
character has to dial back an event here
at an event or two i heard him say that
and also okay good that's just a fact of
life
i'm your feed a does have discretion to
run these candidates the world
championship mesh so that's just sort of
a binding constraint that we're gonna
have to live with okay all the time i
think well you also you were saying it
yourself what a calorie disc players are
enjoying for spectators that's great for
the players very tiring but not only are
we talking about the candidates which is
it's going to be supremely important and
of course the world championship match
later in the year we're also having
Olympiad in the next year so we have so
many events in which this elite players
will be participating difficult to fit
in the grand chester but we're gonna be
doing our best it's still some of the
top level events and you can see the
drama that we're having now today
specially right with our round in zagreb
or an apple Miyaichi was running our way
with the tournament thing the rent came
in and said anymore no no real and back
and rex is always a pleasure thank you
so much for joining and we would ask you
for your expert commentary as to what's
happening in the Magnus game but I don't
want to stress you to know thank you